welcome to the Microsoft translator hub
in this video will show you the basics
of how the translator hub works and what
you'll need to do to get started the
Microsoft translator hub is designed for
use by organizations that have specific
translation needs whether it's for
language preservation warts for specific
domains the purpose is to put creation
improvement and deployment in the hands
of users first let's talk a little bit
about how machine translation works with
the Microsoft translator hub the process
for translating from one language to
another can be broken down into four
basic steps setting up a project
uploading the data training a system to
translate from one language to the other
and finally deploying the system within
each of these steps there are several
activities that need to be completed
once you've signed in more detailed
instructions are provided such as how-to
tutorial videos to help you alone
microsoft translator hub uses a set of
documents that you provide to learn your
language domain and terminology you'll
need what is commonly referred to as
parallel documents these are documents
that are written in both languages but
contain the same information the
languages that you're translating from
and the languages that you're
translating to which we refer to as the
source language and the target language
together these two language are referred
to as a language pair for creating a
translator system between a language
pair in Microsoft translator hub we
suggest that you have approximately two
hundred thousand words or forty thousand
parallel sentences it is possible to
build a translation system with fewer
sentences say approximately ten thousand
however the quality of such a system
will be very low and not very usable in
addition to parallel data you can
provide as many documents in the target
language as possible documents written
in the target language help the
translation system decide whether it can
be considered for alternative
translations which could be more
accurate the first step in getting
started is to request an invitation to
join the Microsoft translator hub simply
click on this link in the translator hub
homepage and request access to the
system be sure to tell us a little bit
about
yourself and your project parentheses
let us know if you're trying to create a
translation model for a specific dialect
of a particular language or whether your
interest is more for research language
preservation or another specific use
once your request has been received
we'll send you an invitation code that
will allow you to log into the system
and get started once you're signed in
you can get started with your first
project we've set up a simple form for
you to fill out and once you've created
the project you can invite others to
join by using our community tools that
allow you to send out invitations to
others you can invite co-owners to help
you manage the projects and reviewers
will help you review the training and
provide suggestions to increase the
accuracy of the resulting translations
community members who are not reviewers
can be included by selecting some
documents and emailing them links to
click on in order to reach the reviewer
UI next you'll set up a training session
so that microsoft translator hub can
learn how words phrases and sentences
are commonly mapped between the two
languages your project will need to be
assembled of parallel and monolingual
documents so you'll need to upload those
next you can upload them as a single zip
file to make it easier Microsoft
translator hub will automatically
extract the documents and remove any
formatting and images so there's no need
to do that ahead of time we're currently
supporting Microsoft Office Word
documents as well as Adobe Acrobat files
HTML plain text and TMX file formats it
may take several training sessions in
order to create an accurate translator
system once a training session has been
successfully completed your translator
system can be deployed for review by
your community of language experts
project owners and invited reviewers
have the ability to review suggested
improvements and can accept or reject
them as appropriate I hope this answers
all of your questions about getting
started with Microsoft translator hub if
you'd like to contact us you can do so
at hub info at Microsoft com
thank you for watching
you